every day it's the same old thing every
summer thousands of pleasure-seeking
tourists head for the great outdoor
playgrounds of America it's more than
thousands millions of American visit our
national parks each year and this spring
one of them decided to give back albeit
it was something she took in the first
place we don't normally get people
sending things next that they have taken
from the park so it was something that
really captured our attention Rangers at
Great Smoky Mountains National Forest
received this letter from a visitor
named Karina in it she writes I loved it
so much I wanted to have a souvenir to
come home with me so I took a rock I'm
sorry and I want to return it enclosed
in the envelope was the rock smaller
than the palm of your hand but still an
important addition to the 1,300 square
mile park we have over 11 million
visitors in this park each year which
means that one rat can be compounded
eleven million times so one rat becomes
11 million rocks one flower becomes 11
million flowers karina drew the rangers
a map of where she found the rock and
this summer the small stone was returned
to the waterfall we just want her to
know that she was admired and we
appreciate her some really cool bro that
wants to take care of her car that's all
we care
priceless you're the map yeah I know she
included a donation in there they don't
actually know her last name so they
really don't know who she is just that
it's Corinna